as the u.s gun control debate
intensifies some americans are looking
overseas for ideas on how to prevent
mass shootings japan has one of the
lowest rates of gun violence in the
world take a look at the stark
comparison the u.s has more than four
firearm homicides per 100 000 people
compared to almost zero in japan
elizabeth farmer reports on the
surprising origin of gun restrictions
placed on japanese citizens
rafael a well-known japanese youtuber is
also ex-military
but before taking up skeet shooting with
instructor takashi maeda he had to get a
gun license which in japan is an ordeal
there's mandatory training you have to
pass a written exam a physical and a
mental health evaluation and even then
the police could go and ask your family
and friends whether you've got any
violent tendencies
from the time you began the process
until you got your license how long did
it take
it took me a year he said
and told me the police had even
interviewed his wife
japanese police do carry handguns but
they're the only ones who can have them
and they are rarely drawn
the ozawa gun shop in tokyo is open
afternoons only
katsumi fukuda the owner offered to show
me around is that you yes
he's proud of the buck he shot in
northern japan with a rifle one of only
three types of gun a civilian can own
air guns are also allowed he said and
shotguns but that's it i've heard that
there's very strict control on
ammunition as well i see you have some
rounds here in the cabinet
hey hey yes he tells me when a gun owner
runs out he needs police authorization
to buy more
does he think the law goes too far
not a bit
like most japanese he supports it as the
price for almost zero gun violence
and how's this for ironic japan owes its
strict gun laws to america the machines
themselves had to be destroyed when the
u.s occupied japan after world war ii it
disarmed the country to the scrap heap
went the guns
americans shaped the legislation that
took firearms out of the hands of
civilians
and to this day that means getting hurt
or killed by a gun in japan
is an extremely long shot
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer tokyo